are you in love with Paul
yes in a very real way me too I'm not
gonna I'm not going to do the jokes
about when we're in jail and all that
kind of stuff but no I'm glad you don't
do the jokes I think it's important for
men to hear how important it is to say I
love Paul Paul Paul's my guy he's my
best friend he's created magic together
we've been saying this longer than
you've been alive because we're older
right he's kind of the brother you know
from my mother from another mother kind
of thing uh we don't agree on all kinds
of things but you've got to understand
the intrinsic
heart and soul of what the relationship
is based on mutual respect he knows
stuff I will never know hopefully I know
some things and one and one equals three
hey we're we're blessed but we didn't
get here overnight and it took a lot of
pitfalls and a lot of a lot of you know
problems and issues over the time you
know Gina and I always haven't always
seen eye to eye and we've had times
great great story was I had five
surgeries to reconstruct my ear they
took a rib cartilage and uh over a
period of time they they reconstructed
an outer ear so it's cosmetically fairly
good and after the first surgery which
was incredibly painful you know what
it's like when a doctor says well you're
going to be a little sore and you wake
up and you can't breathe so you can't
even hit them
um and Gene Gene flew up to uh to
Dartmouth
New Hampshire to come see me which was
uh in a plane that had a gerbil on a
rubber band
and I hate flying I always have I have
nightmares no matter what the logic is
you're struck by lightning more often
blah blah blah blah I hate it you love
Paul and you love the life you guys are
built together and yet I think I have it
right that you guys don't see each other
socially pretty much at all I mean
listen when you tour together and
everything that's when you get to be
together I get that but there is like
maybe well until recently we'd bumpy we
lived a quarter of a mile from each
other I bought another place and maybe
we're a few miles from each it's not
like we don't see each other anytime you
want to have some Starbucks or anything
you know there he is or you'll go to but
you don't do it but you don't do it you
don't make a date of it well how much
can you take we're together more than
married couples we I know we see each
other I'm I'm always happy if if I run
into Gene at the the market or I see
Shannon's like my sister-in-law this is
It's really an extension of my family
and
um I think being Brothers is a little
different than being friends because you
don't want to see them all the time and
you don't always agree but they're the
people time tells everything and you
know from your own relationships that
there's no substitute for time and how
people respond to crises and to your
issues and their own and that bonds you
tremendously
thank you